[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul
and the sun will shine on us again
brother as loki is less than one month
away
the trailer for the new disney plus show
is packed with easter eggs and alternate
versions of the god of mischief
including one that's pulling heavily
from the comic book vault loki
when preparing for a show i often go
through a ton of graphic novels to make
sure i don't miss any references
but i've never made a video before a
series discussing the stories themselves
i realized that there's probably a lot
of people out there who want to know the
full stories of the comics before they
check out the show
so if you're one of them then fret not
your savior is here
throughout this video we'll be breaking
down the full plot of vote loki so you
can get up to speed with the show
if you feel the righteousness surging
within then please click the thumbs up
button
and make sure you subscribe to the
channel otherwise you'll never be a god
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into vote loki
okay so if you're one of those people
who's like keep politics out my comics
then chances are you probably aren't
gonna like vote loki
the graphic novel released in 2016
heavily satirizes the us presidential
election of the same year
but rather than choosing between left
and right it very much puts across the
message that both sides are as bad as
each other
now politicians on the whole have a
reputation for lying
and loki runs his entire campaign on the
basis that he will lie
but unlike the republicans and democrats
he'll do it to your face
even his campaign slogan is believe with
the lie part of that capitalized
to highlight the word lie the book
really encapsulates
spin campaign running and how the media
can be twisted and changed to fit
certain agendas
we primarily see most of the story play
out through the eyes of a woman named
nissa
who as a child had her entire life
changed by a certain battle
in new york after loki threw the
avengers into her housing block
it was completely destroyed and she
became homeless for some time
tony stark agreed to pay for the damages
so that the people had a place to live
and he donated funds to the city however
the corrupt governor at the time
ended up using half the money for his
election campaign and the other half he
put into his own construction projects
nissa ended up becoming a journalist for
the daily bugle
and the character exposed this
corruption because of her reporting
abilities
she was picked to cover the 2016
presidential election
and things really kick off when she goes
to one of the debates
here she meets a buzzfeed reporter named
lucas and nisa notices that there are
slightly different name badges on
certain members of the press
they turn out to be hydra agents and
they launch an attack
but lucas reveals himself to be loki and
he saves the day
he's asked by the reporters there who he
would vote for
and he says neither as both are liars
now the two candidates are clearly based
on trump and hillary
who were running at the time and loki
very much states that people will vote
for whichever lie they believe
he announces that he'll run for
president at this point and that he will
lie to people's faces
and they will love it this openness wins
the public around
and it's not too long before his
election campaign starts to pick up
speed
now in the work they poke some fun at
the whole obama birth certificate
conspiracy theory
and j jonah jameson says that loki can't
run because he's not american
this is where the spin starts and loki
states that because his life is born
from myth and legends
that there have been several different
versions and tellings of his origins
over the centuries
he says that the one we are currently
dealing with is actually american
and that he should be allowed to run
loki goes to nissa who's covering his
campaign
and he tries to convince her that he's
changed she ends up visiting his
headquarters
where he literally changes into lady
loki and
this is important as she's likely gonna
be in the show now we don't know this
for definite
but i believe that the person who
everyone thinks is black widow
is actually her judging by behind the
scenes looks
we know there will be multiple versions
of the character in the show
so the inclusion in that could be
another nod to this work
though she has popped up in other things
too nissa really doesn't gel well with
loki
and she writes a scathing article about
him with the headline
loki will burn washington however this
becomes literal fake news when the
headline is changed to loki's campaign
something to get excited about now
whether loki is behind us or not we
don't know for definite
but the background behind her editor
does change to green
as do his eyes so it seems pretty likely
that this is what happens
the article itself doesn't change though
but everyone only reads the headline and
makes their mind up from that
again this is a comment on how media
reporting often leads with titles that
have nothing to do with the articles
themselves
and it discusses how most people consume
media in this form
rather than actually going past the
headline now jane foster who at this
point is thor
arrives angry that nissa has endorsed
one of her arch enemies
but tempers quickly cool when lisa
explains why she should actually read
what she wrote
issue 2 comes with a cool play on
captain america punching hitler
but instead of him we get caps sucking o
loki on the jaw
there's even a little image of sam
wilson instead of bucky
and you can catch some of loki's
followers who do pop up later
we open this chapter with a campaign ad
which shows a young american
girl named suzy who loves life and carol
danvers
on the opposite side of this is the
leader of doom's children
a lavery and terrorist organization that
becomes a big plot point in the work
loki berates the current two candidates
for trying to negotiate with the group
over skype
instead of just attacking them and says
that because he's fought the hulk before
the people can trust him to get things
done when it comes to conflict
now it wasn't much of a fight though was
it anyway loki also turns the people
against the media
by saying that they report that everyone
who votes for loki is an
idiot which just makes them ride for him
even harder
they get called a brainwashed cult and
again this plays heavily on comments
made during and
after the u.s election lisa starts to
investigate those funding loki
after she's tipped off by jane foster to
who could be bankrolling the campaign
this takes her to a literal cult of
worshippers
who she finds attempting to sacrifice a
goat to their god
lisa films this and though she thinks
it's going to be the thing that ends his
run
loki spins it and says that he's a god
so of course he has worshippers
issue 3 follows nisa as she learns that
loki may actually have hired the hydra
agents to attack the debate
so that he could step in and save the
day though she has no proof of this
the transport they're being moved in
crashes and in the fire she makes out
loki's sister
and bodyguard angela elsewhere loki gets
personally involved in the labyrinth
conflict
which centers around doom's children the
two other candidates say that the usa
shouldn't send troops in to help
and that they should try and talk with
the terrorists which loki spins to say
that they're happy to work with them
nissa disguises herself as one of the
liberian rebels
and sneaks into doom's castle in order
to steal some weapons
doom's children arrive to kill the
forces and one of the rebels says that
now would be a good time to try out the
weapons he sneaks off whilst the two
groups go head to head
and we see that one of the weapons has
an explosive strap to it
which goes off killing both sides it's
revealed that this mysterious rebel was
actually loki
and nisa films his transformation she
finally thinks that she's got him on the
ropes
and sends the video out as she boards a
plane nissa is gleeful throughout the
entire flight
believing that she's finally stopped him
however when she lands
she learns that he's put some spin on it
to say that he'd do anything to protect
u.s
troops and would rather put himself in
harm's way the public
love it and loki becomes more popular
than ever
nissa gives up trying to take him down
and issue four sees a mutant attempting
to assassinate loki
he's saved by his sister and she's then
directed by loki to go and contact nisei
she meets her with thor and says that
loki's alter ego lucas from buzzfeed
is actually the leader of hydra and
nissa's suspicions
are confirmed this is exposed to the
public
and they're split right down the middle
those still loyal to loki are willing to
fight no matter what
and those against the god end up dumping
trash on his supporters launce
loki visits nissa once more and tells
sir this
isn't what he wanted he's not the god of
chaos and would rather have things
peaceful than a country on the brink of
civil war
he goes onto tv to talk to america and
his supporters
and states that he's going to be leading
the country i would rather do that with
everyone unified
people in the audience start asking how
he's going to accomplish his goals
but it becomes clear that he's just
spouting off catchphrases
without any real plan loki's supporters
lose all faith in him and it becomes
clear that there's no way
loki can win the election nissa is
offered a tv show after being the only
person who is willing to speak out
against him
and just as she hangs up the god of
mischief appears
the pair talk about how her career has
come on leaps and bounds since covering
him
and loki slightly plays his hand he
hints that he carried out the entire
election campaign as a way to right the
wrongs of his past
and to make up for destroying her home
all those years ago
loki states that he's going to concede
and he flies off into the sky
however a big twist comes when he takes
a phone call with an unnamed candidate
and reveals that he actually destroyed
his chances of winning so that this
mystery person could win the election
instead
we don't know what happens next but it's
clear that this candidate gives him
something special as a thank you
and we now know that loki has the future
president in his pocket
that's how the book ends and though i
doubt the show version of the character
will follow these plot points
it's going to be interesting to see how
the arc is adapted for the show
vote loki is a fun book that perfectly
parodies politics
however i don't know if it's for
everyone and there are parts in it that
i feel
just don't work i'm not a massive fan of
the art style
and do prefer more photo realistic
comics like libra majo and alex ross
however you do quickly gel with the
cartoon style and it helps to keep
things quite light
as you read it the book is only four
issues long and there's a lot more going
on in it than i've covered
so if it's piqued your interest then i
definitely think you should check it out
obviously i'd love to hear your thoughts
on this story and how you think it'll be
brought into the show
comment below and let me know and as a
thank you for interacting with the video
you'll be entered into a prize through
on the 30th of may
which we're giving away three copies of
the godzilla vs kung collection
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on and
drop a comment below with your thoughts
on the comic
the winners of last month's competition
are on screen right now so if that's you
then message me on twitter heavyspoilers
you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
love death and robot season 2
which will be linked on screen right now
we've gone over the full series from top
to bottom so it's definitely worth
checking out
if you want something else to watch
right after this by the way thank you
for sticking through the video
i've been poor i'll see you next time
take care peace